thank you we are going to make America
so great again you want to know the
absolutely most important thing about
the results of the New Hampshire
primaries the winners aren't even real
members of the parties for whose
nomination they're running Bernie
Sanders an avowed socialist when his
Senate seat as an independent
cheri caucuses with the Democrats and
many of his policy positions fit easily
within the donkey party's tent but it's
nothing short of amazing that he's the
one giving Hillary Clinton the scare of
her lifetime something similar goes for
Donald Trump who is registered as a
Democrat in the past supports universal
health care and is nobody's idea of a
rock ripped Republican not only did
these guys win last night and come in
second in Iowa they're responsible for
record turnouts - every survey shows the
same thing a majority of Americans are
frustrated with the electoral choices
they're being offered in trusting
confidence in government and authority
are at historic lows as a whole the
nation is socially liberal and fiscally
conservative and until we get a party or
two that speaks to that great growing
group of crypto libertarians who just
want to get on with a life that will
mostly be lived beyond politics you can
expect more independent candidates
making life very difficult for
traditional party types so regardless of
how you feel about Donald Trump or
Bernie Sanders take a moment to thank
them for revealing just how little
voters care for the Democratic and the
Republican parties for reason TV I'm
Nick Gillespie
you